FORSBERG IS THE CLOSEST THING
THE SENATORS HAVE TO SHOT IT
GOES
HESITATE.
THE SHOCK GETSWANTED.
SMITH BACK TO NEUTRAL ZONE.
>> WHAT I LIKE ABSOLUTE
FLURRY LAST SHIFT.
ALL KIND OF
LEAD.
THE GAME FLIPPED.
WIDE.
CHECKED BY JOHNSON A A THE DOOR
REBOUND.
PAVEL WHIPS OFF THE FAR PIKE AND
THE DEVILSOMEWHAT SCRAMBLING IN
CENTER OF THE ZONE.
NORRIS TO SKATE IT GETHIGH.
CHASED OUT TO CENTER BY IN.
THE DEVILS GOT THEHE
COMES
THEY DON'T FIND THAT LOOSE PUCK.
THAT FINDS A WIDE OPENED OWN NO.
HUGHES TRYING TO KEEP THE PUCK
IN AND  IT WAS FROM
THE SLOT THAT TOLD ME THE EFFOR
DEVILS TAKE A  HERE.
HE HAS GIVEN UP TWO  PASS THEY
KEEP ANOTHER PUCK ALIVE.
TKACHUK BANGS IN  OTTOWA.
NICERSEY.
THIS IS A GREAT THEM WORK.
THEY ALMOST SCORE.
>>
WIDE.
>> HE HAD ALL KIND OF ROOM.
RIPPED IT UP HIGH OVER THE NET.
>> HISCHIER TO PROTETE 20 SHOTS
DOWN HAMILTON NORRIS ON THE
FACE-OFF.
TKACHUK AND ZCENTER.
ON THE REENTRY, HUGHES WRIST SH
HAMILTON.
>> TEN SECONDS LEFT IN
THERE JOSH NORRIS HAS SCORED
ONCE IN THREE SHOOTOUT ATTEMPTS
>>BATHERSON IN THE NIGHT
HAPPILY FOR THETWO-POINT NIGHT ,
IN ON BLACKWOOD, BLACKWOOD FEATS
HIM OFF.
OVER.
JOHNSSON INNER ON FORSBERG, HE
SHOOTS BY